okay s what was
that hold on
this this is
adrenaline and then you say trust me you
have I'm the Batman you're Batman okay
that's like this is the cake this is
cake either way happy birthday little
suszie Q yeah I bet you want the cake no
I want cake fewer words less time before
that Cake's in my mouth bro bro bro
you're messing this whole thing up okay
you want cake or you want the
cake
all right great take four B Mar you're
[__] fired what no I'm your
replacement yeah it's kind of like uh
you know when the coach sends a new guy
in to relief the picture a relief
picture to be honest I'm kind of lost
with all the sports references I kind of
threw one out there not knowing you take
it any further but truth be told oh crap
no I keep forgetting be told I don't
know I don't follow baseball I actually
think it's barbaric and it promotes
toxic masculinity okay well I hope this
doesn't hurt your feelings but I'm Nolan
[__] Ryan and I'm waving you back to
the bench I told you I don't follow
Sports look at that suit so
2005 hello is this 2005 it's it's for
you
yes we want our suit back okay I'm glad
you're here cuz you're the only one that
would think this is still a sick
Bird that's not a real hand
slide Gotham deserves so much better
than this
I
those curtains are see-through numb nuts
nuh-uh yeahuh nuh-uh I can see your arm
it's creeping
out what about now yeah you look like
the shroud of
Trin not many options in here okay you
go to the crime scene aren't the police
there yeah they've done their work God
godamn those poys in blue s a fan I just
figured it out you show up after the
crime has been committed you don't fight
and you don't solve [__] you're not the
Batman you're the Robin take that back
Robin no trap peas boy I'm not a bat I'm
the
bat do you want an Advil I don't need
Advil I thrive on pain oh that's pretty
cool yeah
thanks
okay what are you
doing I'm taking pictures of you with my
contact L's cameras Oh great are they
prescription actually yes take one of
these print it up poster size so you
never forget to can play that game all
right I got another one with your name
on
it this
is you know the cure for Crime shouldn't
look like the lead singer from The Cure
just my taste we're basically the same
looking you're so mopy I just feel like
you might be more comfortable in The
Suicide
Squad that's actually really insensitive
I get put on suicide watcha lot too dark
good all
right
[Music]
ah